surf's up democrats in california trying
to cancel hard work here's their idea
state reps are proposing a four day work
week for companies with more than 500
employees that's right they're proposing
shortening your office work week from 40
hours to just 32 hours but get this part
your salary stays the same so it's 32
hours of work for 40 hours of pay
and if you want to work more than 32
hours you have to get paid time and a
half for overtime and remember this is
happening in the midst of an alarming
labor shortage in america employers
cannot find workers there's somewhere
around 10 million jobs unfilled in this
country right now are they lazy this
generation judge is that what it is or
or have they figured out life is short
we've been taught to work so hard you
waste your whole life working you could
be taking it easy and get over time okay
let me tell you what's going to happen
if you're in a country if you're in a
company with more than 500 employees you
have to work 32 hours instead of 40
hours that means every everybody else is
going to say i only want to work 32
hours or i'm going to quit my job okay
and the problem then is that after 32
hours they're going to say oh i only
want to work 25 hours this is the
beginning of the end as far as i'm
concerned okay nobody wants to work
anymore everybody's lazy the pandemic's
a mess people are walking around in
pajamas in the supermarket they go to
church in their pajamas i don't get it
that's all i have to say nobody wants to
work every week workers are dressed
better than these people
you know the uh
the problem with keeping businesses open
greg is is critical
now i mean they the
restaurants close now
monday and tuesday uh you know they
shorten hours there's no one it's
destroying my social life
and that's when when it starts when it
starts hurting me i care but you know
what i think they realize they realize
in a 40-hour week 40-hour week
maybe at most you work 32 hours right
you know what the thing is there is a
lot of inefficiency built in the in the
workplace including even coming and
going to work having a i never
understood a lunch hour but then again i
don't have kids i don't need to run to
the you know to do errands so i just sit
around and i'm i always have you know my
sis i'd pull a jesse and have my
assistant do everything but you know
what this is going to be this is going
to end up turning us into a virtual
reality cocoon
everybody's just going to evolve into
staying home they're going to get
everything they need at their house
they're going to get really large
and the only people that are going to be
in the outside world or the people who
can't afford the inside world
jesse has the
the appearance of darris bueller type
person but he works very hard right now
thanks geraldo is that a question
here's what i think geraldo i've stopped
caring about the millennials
californians
here's why i used to feel sorry for
california i used to try to fix
california we have to do this we have to
do that nope what do we care they voted
for these people this is a democracy
it's on you guys if you guys want to
have homeless tent cities with meth
heads running around and get free food
and free cash you guys do you will be
normal in the rest of the 49. we can't
help california
they have to help themselves
like france they do have but not ours
it's funny that you say that i wrote
france right here on my favorite because
if you want to be more like france
there's
eat more croissants
don't go this route the other thing is
they did in france if you look at their
economy they're terrible but also for a
while they were like well we don't
really want to
put our defense money into nato because
it's like we want to spend money on it
we don't have enough okay i'm not trying
to do a french accent um
you're not allowed yes you are the
employer is not allowed
to contact you on the weekend it is
illegal for an email to be sent to you
on the weekend in france for example and
here's the other thing if a company
thinks that they can attract more talent
by saying you're going to work 32 hours
a week at this salary great but the
government shouldn't tell people to do
that i think greg would be in prison if
he was french
saturday morning
how do you know that i know everything
i know things i don't want i've received
some of those the fastest is up next hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else